ich saß vor einigen tagen da und habe
überlegt was abbas könnte eine coole
idee für neues video für euch leute sein
und da ist mir eingefallen wie wär es
leute wie wäre es wenn wir mal einen
blick auf etwas werft mit dem wir
eigentlich schon abgeschlossen haben und
mal checken wie hilf mir sich entwickelt
hat der name ist ausgesprochen hat ihr
wisst publikum es geht es geht um hilf
mir
das heißt die ganze angelegenheit wird
nicht leicht für uns werden ich habe
eine folge rausgesucht die zumindest
fällt auch ein bisschen erträglich ist
die ersten titel verliebt in die tochter
meiner putzfrau an der biblischen folgen
der letzten monate und wochen angestellt
ich kenne diese leute ok ja das kann und
das ist die bextor wie dabei also wir
haben einmal diese junge frau hier auf
der linken seite merle diese merle ist
in einen verliebt das ganze ist so
entstanden dass ihre mutter die mutter
von mehr dabei der familie von jörn
putzt und übrigens wissen warum
aschenputtel heißt google für euch und
das liegt daran dass in dem märchen das
mädchen aschenputtel in der asche neben
dem herd schlafmuster wenn so krank
ärmlichen verhältnissen lebt und
scheinbar laut hilf mir ist das ist
gleich geblieben
die mutter aber mama liebt mich und dem
ist es egal dass wenig geld haben und er
ist noch lange diese fassung wie seine
mutter das müssen wir wirklich glauben
ja sind wir im mittelalter oder wie sind
wir mittelalter leute kommt es mit
heutzutage doch auf die stände an ja
auch darauf den stand in dem man geboren
wurde
also wurde man als adliger geboren darf
man nur adlige heiraten ist es ist noch
so aktuell in deutschland
es gibt ja ich weiß natürlich auch es
gibt glaube ich schon gewissen rtl2
sender der der meinung ist das ist noch
so
und außerdem hat seine mutter mich zum
abendessen eingeladen
ja die eltern möchten mich anscheinend
kennen lernen möglich ein bisschen
vermisst aber so diese e-mails rockigen
dialoge und dann immer dieses wenn
jemand irgendwas sagt was auch nur
entfernt irgendeine relevanz hat mir das
thema du wirst ein tolles mädchen aber
denkt ja nicht geraten was du dich mit
jemanden treffen kann aus einem haushalt
der ansatzweise ein bisschen mehr
verdient als wir weil wir leben immer
noch im mittelalter okay ich weiß du
schaust auf dein handy und schoss auf
das jahr und da steht 2020 aber wir
leben im mittelalter ist es nach wie vor
verboten für leute außerhalb ihres
standes zu heiraten
[Musik]
sogar die kaffeetasse leuchtet so leben
reich alles so leuchtet leute alles
leute die kaffeetasse leuchtet die hecke
leuchtet wasser leuchtet sowieso alles
leuchtet die zeitschrift leuchtet sogar
auch und natürlich im hintergrund sohn
gedudel ganz klar weil leute wie gesagt
so leben reiche club mir
freust dich schon heute abend ja die
mörder kommt ja ja ich weiß gar nicht
warum ich mich dazu breitschlagen diesem
hintergrund dieses mal klar alter okay
ich gehe es gut so ihr habt ein schönes
haus muss wirklich sagen also noch von
teur haus sieht gut aus aber ihr seid
keine französischen adelsfamilie okay
also ihr braucht euch dieses gedudel im
hintergrund aber dass durch eine für
dich damit du das weiß aber wer weiß
vielleicht hat es ja auch sein gutes
dann siehst du wenn dieses mal wie sich
deine kleine freundin auf
gesellschaftlichem parkett bewegt
vielleicht lassen als das ist nichts für
dich es ich sage es wirklich also diese
frau glaubt sie glaubt wirklich dass sie
die direkte tochter der queen von
england ist scheinbar andererseits wer
will es ihr verübeln leute wie würdet
ihr denken wenn eure kaffeetasse
leuchtet und sogar eure zeitschrift also
das was ich gesehen habe das reicht mir
das war einfacher verhältnisse einfache
gemüter
es war das pure proletariat also bitte
[Musik]
so sind die reichen deutschland ja nicht
dass ich wüsste aber so city lesen
zeitschriften und komischen bilder die
tasse leuchtet aus der getrunken wird
die hecke leuchtet alles leuchtet leute
ja eigentlich müssen reiche auch den
ganzen sonnenbrillen tragen weil alles
erleuchtet
okay da so ist es einfach weiß ich das
aussieht gestehe ich denn dann bitte
schon da hast du darüber mal gedanken
und das steht ja hatten seine eltern
früher mehr geld als miralles mutter
nein also du warst genauso aber das
kannst du nicht vergleichen es helfen
das kannst du nicht vergleichen weil
jetzt leuchtet meine kaffeetasse die
ohren so aber alle bisher mein okay na
gut mir völlig korrekt von ihr auf jeden
fall
sie war früher selbst kann selbst aus
normalen oder einfachen verhältnissen
und hat dann quasi irgendwie klang
schließlich selbst karriere gemacht oder
gleich mal geheiratet was auch immer und
natürlich natürlich wie sie jetzt damit
nichts mehr zu tun haben mit ihrer
eigenen vergangenheit alter kasper chloe
hat vollkommen überholte vorstellungen
zum thema beziehung natürlich sehen
eltern die partnerwahl ihres nachwuchses
oftmals sehr kritisch
chloe verurteilt die freundin ihres
sohnes hier aufs schlimmste vollkommen
vollkommen korrekt leute wir sind weil
wir sind nach wie vor dem mittelalter
meine lieben damen und herren dieses
fernsehsenders rtl 2 da hab ich euch
darauf hinweisen dass ihr selbst eine
metaphorik ja einen vergleich aus einem
märchen selbst ab das stimmt das
verhalten das sie hier an den tag legt
geht überhaupt nicht geld sogar die
wehrleute das geht überhaupt nicht das
geht überhaupt nicht das geht überhaupt
nicht das ist für seine hauptaufgabe der
weise er sagt es ist einfach nur was
geht und was nicht geht wobei eigentlich
sagt er nur was nicht geht er ist mister
das geht überhaupt nicht das geht
überhaupt nicht das geld ist genau
eingeplant du musst mit dem 50 euro
taschengeld die woche aber 15 euro wovon
der von dem von meinem taschengeld und
damit kriegen stock ein lustiges
kleidung
moment moment moment im moment 50 euro
taschengeld die woche
ja sie ist zwar 18 50 euro taschengeld
die woche gab das habe ich in meinem
leben noch nie bekommen ja also wenn das
denn das jetzt hier arme oder einfache
verhältnisse sind dann komme ich ja
scheinbar direkt aus der gosse ups mir
fällt ein ich habe nie eine maus geboren
wurde in der kanalisation alter okay
hier ein bisschen vorgespult darf
natürlich nicht fehlen leute ist dass es
sich laut davon leuchtet ein klettern
aber noch nicht du wirst das du wirst
sehen wenn du gleich ich spreche man
direkt zu ihrer männer
wenn du nachher bei jahren bei der
familie zu gast sein wirst wird deine
kaffeetasse nicht leuchten und wenn du
der zeitschrift anfasst wird auch diese
nicht schlimmer ich kann es jetzt schon
mal sagen du fliegst sofort auf v-leute
sie hat jetzt ihr kleid gekauft ich habe
euch mal den prozess des kleid kaufen
ersparte war relativ unrelevant deswegen
ist jetzt weiter sie ist bei ihm
moment moment kann kann kurz bitte mal
die kirche da drüben die fresse halten
ja ich nehme mir da ein video auf wo wir
müssen unsere religion aus spaß
das würde ich ganz gerne mal wissen
wollte um jeden tag um 18 uhr läutet
diese gottverdammte glocke warum
eigentlich ist da jeden tag zum
gottesdienst stopp nicht oder ist ich
weiß es nicht auf jeden fall leute wir
müssen wir festhalten ihr kleid glitzert
das kann nach meinen berechnungen ist
das eigentlich nicht mögt das kann nicht
sein
ihr könnt ihr kleid kann eigentlich
nutzern die kommt aus einer normalen
familie bleiben wir doch weg alter
woher hast du dieses offensichtlich so
teure zeiteinsatz der sehr authentisch
ist der sind natürlich ist der in dieser
art und weise sehr oft gesagt wird was
dieses offensichtlich woher hast du
dieses offensichtlich so teure kleid
dass meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren nennt man einen beschissenen text
ganz ehrlich weißt du was ich mache hier
unten mal die anmerkung anja schau mal
unten rechts in die ecke mach einfach
mal deine augen aufdecker bist du den
blindgänger schaut einfach mal unten
rechts in die ecke von dem bild jetzt
hier gerade da steht doch hilft mir was
meinst du wie die an ihr kleid gekommen
ist denkst du jetzt gekauft oder wie für
den vollen preis
so jetzt der große abenteuer
schlichter geht ja auch einen
abschlussball was ist los bei euch oder
auch die übertreiben müssen ja ja ich
meine also gut wenn wir uns das haus
anschauen dann geht es der familie da
nicht schlecht aber wie gesagt wir
wollen wir auf dem boden bleiben ja das
ist es jetzt auch nicht dass jetzt auch
kein hochadel also mal ganz davon
abgesehen dass hat also sorry
denn der junge kommt ihren anzug der
kragen steht keine cover egal also sorry
bitte was ist das denn und ganz ehrlich
also von dieser farbkombination von
diesem von seinem vater kriege ich ja
auch mal fettesten ausschlag was ist das
denn ein komisches blau mit zum lila
bitte nicht das lassen wir doch lieber
für ihre mutter morgen früh stehen
dankeschön das ist ja wirklich zusagt
ich alte frau sowie unverhältnismäßiger
auch man lässt die teller auf dem tisch
stehen bis zum nächsten morgen sagt sie
einfach nur um sie zu rosten
das ist wirklich knackig noch von um die
frage zu beantworten heute was ist aus
hilf mir geworden hilft mir das
eigentlich noch genauso wie früher als
es immer noch dieselbe schmerzhafte
erfahrung nur dass einige leute
mittlerweile gelernt haben und sich das
nicht mehr rein ziehen also die klicks
konnten sie deutlich runtergegangen ich
würde mir das jetzt nach diesem letzten
wiedersehen auch nicht mehr geben leute
ihr kriegt hier ein vorgeschaltetes
video in kelberg arabien
ich bin schnell raus macht's gut
woher hast du dieses offensichtlich zu
teure kleid